[Music]
hey babe
hey babe hey babe welcome to another
episode of sal and chris present
hey babe i like it i like it i like it i
like it okay
so yeah yeah our hair by the way
something just happened with your hair
what yeah
i ran my hands through it yeah it's a
totally different style
yeah it's one of it's one of the things
i have that i actually like about myself
my hair is very flexible and malleable
it's you got a
nice bounce to your hair if you're a guy
i could tell just from sitting we could
be sitting on a plane for hours
your hair bounces when you walk and i
like that this is covered beard
obviously i look like i just have a
fistful of cubes glued to my face
yeah this is covered beard and hair i've
yet to i'm
nervous because here's what i've here's
what i learned about during
this time period viral load right yes
you know what it is
viral load i didn't know what it was but
now i do
so you want to explain to the people so
what i read and uh you know you could
you could be on the side if it's a hoax
you could be on the side of you know
my brother died you know god bless but
uh it happens whatever it is we know
somebody
we know something's going on right so
here's what i said let me just take
every precaution i can to not get this
thing so
what i read an article that made sense
is you know distance is for a reason so
the
proximity to someone right and how long
you're with them
okay is a big key factor so if you had
cove and you jogged by me outside i'm
like hey babe and i was like hey babe
odds are i'm okay right if you had cove
and you jogged by me in the apartment
and said hey babe uh i might be a little
less okay or if
or if we were doing the podcast known as
hey babe and i had cove right now
that's the worst possible scenario we
are dead yeah we're
because it's it's how close you are to
someone and for how long now
what is a hairdresser at least one who's
worth this salt
do for you they hover an orbit in and
around your head
yeah this close right cutting cutting
cutting cutting right i have the best
hairdresser
ever i love the guy yeah got shout out
to max love max
as well and uh he takes minimum
one hour on my hair yeah the guy is a
surgeon and he cares about his job he's
passionate
right and in a lifetime of haircuts and
this is nothing against my my buddy tony
who used to cut my hair yeah 10 years
and i was younger
but just as of right now after after
tony i i was you ever have you ever have
no barber to commit to
and you do that yeah you ever do that
when you're like oh i got to look what's
in the
area when you need this cut you gotta
look what's in the area and then when
you walk in
you could look at the people first of
all let's break this down a little bit
you ever go in and you see someone that
is a hairdresser then their hair sucks
oh yeah it's the worst that's for me
that is five alone
i can't do it yeah you don't go anywhere
in that person if they went to school
for this and it's their job
and they're they're okay looking like
that right whether it's some weird
you know they didn't layer it right or
there's a weird line over here or yeah
can't do it
okay so but then you look and then you
say all right i gotta trust that person
but then that person's not available
right and then you're like well you got
you know whoever over here we can slot
you with
carl whatever and you're like all right
and then you come out you're like uh i
got a
a month to like correct us right that's
when you're in no man's land when you
cause i used to do that i used to just
be like what neighborhood am i in right
now filming
i need a haircut let me look it up let
me walk in and
you you're lucky if you're 50 50 success
rate
every time i've done that i've come out
i've looked in the mirror i say
i look like a pineapple it's just what
it is that's just what
you come out with just a bad haircut
yeah but but so let me
okay well max so he's going to hover
around my head
for one hour now he wears a mask okay
even i wear a mask
but but it's the worst possible viral
load situation
because if he has droplets or i have
droplets right then you're just getting
fed droplets for the hour even through
the master don't get well
i don't know i don't i'm not i don't
create these masks what if we did
something where we wrapped you
you know put like a hazmat suit on and
saran wrap and the only thing that was
coming out of this you had to breathable
we gave you things where you could open
up
and breathe you had a you could breathe
from the inside but just your hair was
out
it would be like he's just cutting the
top he doesn't even see your face well
sure
just sit in there with your hair out if
you can get a patent on that and get it
produced yeah like a suit
also i have to if he's gonna do anything
with this which currently this looks
like
something let's be honest with you yeah
i mean what if i really wanna because
what happens is i'm home right now right
we're in the house
but if i have to go somewhere a lot of
times i actually had to
i now have bought a a
heat i heat my beard up and straighten
it
why is that funny it's a product that
they have this like straighten out your
beard hair
no well my tear is so tightly curly and
it gets
wild it's unruly and wax doesn't do
enough to keep it down yeah and so what
i do is i bought this argan oil
right i know the smell because it's a
smell that i smell in women's hair my
whole life glue to my mom's
it's the oil that protects you against
heat burn so i got this stuff i slather
it all
up and then i got this comb and it's
like it's essentially like a like a
girls have curling irons right it's like
made for beards and the bristles heat up
to 400 degrees
jesus and then you go like but it
doesn't burn you it's like made to not
burn you
there's like 50 of them available like
different brands so this is a big market
i didn't know about it i've never heard
of it i
do it i do it for about you know two to
three minutes right then my beard is not
curly it's straight and it's like this
long and then i put the wax in a little
bit
and then it looks like i start to look
like a normal normal human man sometimes
i was just well i mean i if your beard
hair is down here you don't look like a
normal human man to be you look
a normal human that has a beard that
works a normal human man from
from bce times from before christ well
let's let's let's be honest what do i
look like even now i don't know what i
look like
i was that good now i was mo first of
all i totally 100 disagree i told you
this last week when i saw you for the
first time
in a couple months i think the new look
this new rugged you with the long and
long beard is 100
your look it feels like i think 100
moving forward but it's interesting
because i was moments away from saying
i think you look like a really rough
fisherman and then you cut me off and
said i straightened my beard here
so a fisherman would not be
straightening their beard there but
that's what i love about you sal yeah
that's what i love about doing the show
with you
is you you if you want to judge if
that old saying don't judge a book by
its cover you're the definition
because the cover the cover of the book
says i'm a fisherman yeah those pages
say gay gay gay
and i understand and you got to read you
got to read the forward and you got to
read every chapter
and then you got to read the index even
before you make a judgment now it's no
it should be no shock and maybe this
maybe the title will come into this
sal and i i think are a couple of guys
who are on
defend the gay fence i say there's a
spectrum
i've had many questions asked hey chris
tell the truth are you gay
i'm not support the gays love the gays
not gay you
have one do the same thing people said
that guy's gay ng
yeah and it's like look i'm not gay if
you google my name
the first thing that comes up is if you
put isa volcano
gay gay yeah is he gay is he married is
he
is he is he straight is he but it's
always questioning my sexuality now i
know this and
i talk about on the show here's one
thing that happened we did a sketch show
a long time ago where we um
we had a sketch show on tv right
short-lived it was fun
uh and uh we did a sketch where we were
on sally jesse raphael we got her to do
it
daytime actual sally just yeah that's
sick daytime talk show
and the sketch was um like making fun of
like not making like like it was like
like the jerry springer type deals so i
go i bring the guys on the show to tell
them i'm gay
right then they flip out and then um one
of them says i can't believe this but
like you've emboldened me
since you admitted it i'm admitting it
right and then i'm like
he goes i'm gay and then i go well this
is crazy because the only reason i said
i was gay is because i knew you were and
i wanted to help you come out
i'm not gay right and then it goes on
and on
and she was in and they someone clipped
that and put it up out of context and
they
people think it's a sally jesse raphael
episode that's hilarious that i came out
as gay on
we're going to post it well we could
post it yeah and it doesn't
hurt that i also you know i also
skew effeminate and sometimes when i
fool around and joke around
like i don't mind i i get silly like
that yeah and and and so
it doesn't help that i also i'm also
very in touch with my feelings
and my feminine side i'll cry i told you
i cry doesn't take anything for me to
cry i know i cry
so easily i cry often right i'm not
saying i sit and have
a long weep but tears welling up tears
streaming down commercial can do it
yeah i'm i agree and i know that about
you and i love that about you and i
think that's why we have such a common
bond because it's like
same thing i'm very in touch on my
sensitive side i don't care you want to
call me again you want to think i'm gay
that's totally fine i've said this on
podcast before i fall in love with men i
have sex with women that's just what it
is yeah so i'm having a great
conversation with you
i'm gonna bang the crap out of my
girlfriend right
and i'm gonna be thinking about you
straightening your beard hair
yeah i love the gays tons of gay friends
in my life my whole life tons of gay
fans through the games
defense gay people come up to me all the
time i get hit on by gay men
it's no thing god bless them yeah you
know like i just say
i'm sorry that i misled you yeah uh but
i'm sorry i talked this way and act this
way but yeah it's the same with me it's
like i'm not i get dm
constantly by you know not constantly
but i've been dm by quite a few gay men
saying hey
you know i i think you're gay i i i had
gay men say
you don't know you're gay yet but i do
so let's just speed this up
right you know listen listen i you know
and and but it's one of those things
also too we have a lot of hand motions
we do a lot maybe
might jazz hands or something like that
because it's not even like italian hands
it's not even a tie hands
i'm very i've i'm talking like a woman
yeah no i don't care
when i'm talking i think if someone
closes their eyes
i think if someone closes mute this and
watch us tell me it's not a podcast
about two guys
even live in a very nice skate like i
think if you mute this if i think if you
mute this
and you just watch us doing hand motions
you'll say this is a podcast this is
like
these are two gay men talking about
furniture and and different western i
thought i'd say like
by the way you want to talk furniture
for one hour i'm your guy yeah i love
nothing
by the gay but i swear to god i love
even my interests i love
nothing more than a houseware give me a
good housewares store yeah i go to
i love housewares i love to talk about
housewares i love talking retail i'm an
educated consumer you know this
yeah i i shop till i drop yeah i
watch uh i'm trying to come off social
media a lot now because i'm just like
it's too negative for me and i'm
focusing my people asking what would you
do if you weren't a comedian
one million percent interior design yeah
i watch architectural digest episodes
i've seen every episode like 10 times
yeah it's all i have the books i just
flip through them you love it it's like
my you're the one that's talking about
my porn you're the one that told me
about restoration hardware i don't even
know i used to call it hardware
restoration you said you look like an
idiot out there it's restoration
hardware
but but but so and you're a guy but see
that's why i like it most guys would be
like you know what i don't want to let
anybody know you're saying it right here
to america or to or
or and abroad you are saying it's
countries abroad i believe that this
podcast will go internationally
if we can get the international rights
[Laughter]
and so that's what i love about it so
yeah and i think it's interesting
because you'd say
if you know the eyes closed i mean uh uh
the the podcast on mute you'd say these
gay guys do an interior design
if you if you had it if you had just i
mean i mean look at like
that and that's me and the girl with the
pearl earring but it's me
and then the way we actually talk so our
mannerisms say that and then the way we
actually talk so if you just had if you
just had the volume on and you never see
it you don't know who the hell we are
you would i think the the listener would
say they would say
i didn't know that fran drescher had a
podcast that's what
they would say these guys both sound
like the nanny in different ways
true or something that's not like rocky
balboa got literally punched in the
teeth yeah yeah
i have no diction yeah when i go back
and listen to myself
i don't think i sound like i have a
heavy accent and then sometimes i go
back and
i don't pronounce half the things i say
yeah one time robert kelly the great
robert kelly said
uh that's all right that means yeah that
me and sal both sound like a gay joan
rivers
i agree that here's what i did before i
came out you know you said my hair
changed
yeah we were recording earlier so what i
did was out of the shower
because the hair is so long now i slick
it back i put in a medium hole gel
and i get it to a place i do a spray a
number four spray of tresemme
right which is a stronghold but not the
strongest because i want stiff i want it
to be
have a hold but also be a little soft
then after about an hour when we did the
podcast my hair dried
right so it wasn't wet anymore now i can
run my hands through it i don't have to
have such a tight hold
and now it falls and it loosens up and
now when i'm here i don't have to worry
that hair is out of place
right it's two different mindsets when i
had the hair slicked back tight i feel
like almost like
the guy would that murders people and
from the movie in the 80s ted bundy
no um psycho psycho yeah jordan
psycho yeah no oh christian bale yeah
you know like that whole like oh bob um
what's his name
what's that guy's character's name uh
kid patrick bateman
yeah bateman yeah yeah yeah so like you
feel like patrick bateman norman bates
you think it's a lot of bait with the
serial killer i wonder if there was
inspiration there
interesting google it google it we so i
would do that
but i always find myself getting a stiff
neck because i'm always worried that it
hasn't gone please
so what i did was i freed myself from
that before the spot because i freed
myself i run my hands through it
and now i have body and bounce and i
have volume and it's smart because we're
doing it's no
it's no shock here we're doing we did uh
two episodes in one day and you
went with a different hair look but with
the same shirt yeah because it wasn't to
fool anybody it was literally for my own
comfort right
it wasn't i wasn't trying to flex that i
could have all these different hair
styles
but i could if i wanted to but i'm not
trying to do that yeah just understand
he could if he wanted
if i wanted to you guys would be blown
away you know what else you're great at
is you
once told me it was fascinating because
you said the most
important things go ahead you could do
in your life
is get a comfortable pillow and
comfortable shoes i said sal why
he said sixty percent of your life is on
is is is on the pillow
40 on your feet is that other numbers
you threw out at me a third of our life
is in bed
a third of all i said bedding pillow is
it pillows
pillow is paramount yeah but betting
altogether right don't
ever ever waste any don't i mean don't
even think twice about
indulging even if it's your last like
you know like if you're going to spend
it on like
weed or you want to go to like get a
drink yeah or whatever you want a new
pair of sneakers or whatever whatever it
is whatever pay the child support but
yeah
other than that you put that money into
a mattress
right and not just where everyone goes
i'm not saying that
mattresses that most popular ones you
can name right now aren't the best right
but
go on a mattress lay on it right pick
the one money should be no object when
coming to a mattress save all your
pennies
don't even get to bed sleep rough right
until you can afford it but once you can
afford it you get the right matches you
get the right linens
you get a comforter for the winter and a
comforter for the summer i'm telling you
because sleep is very important and
sometimes people use all season all your
comforter right
we're not savage we don't have to do
that yeah you get yourself one and what
you do is in the summer you go to a
much lighter right you don't want to be
tossing and turning and you won't be
overheated and then you're throwing the
covers off but then the air's on and
then you're freezing and you put them
back on
by the time you get up you're getting
cold your voice is thrown over
you have to put yourself in the most
comfortable position and then pillows
best pillow i've ever gotten ham lacquer
ham lacquer and schlemmer i'm a hammock
or slimmer hammacher schlemmer yeah i'm
locker
i have those too they're the cool
pillows with the gel inserts they stay
cool they flip you know
i don't know how they stay cool but i'm
telling you i've never once turned over
that pillow and it'd be
anything warmer than i want to say 50
degrees fahrenheit
i i've i'm starting out mine are
starting to show some signs of where
wow how many years in i well i'm about
i'm about three years in now
three years no no but i don't use one
pillow i have uh
in this house i have maybe 20 pillows
right now granite is because we have
different areas but even for my own
bed i have a two sets of down two sets
of
um uh what do you call it um
the opposite of down it's uh up
no the uh simulator whatever what the
frick they call it i don't know i'm
blanking right now but it's it's not
damn it's not the feather it's the um
just not foam but it's like i can't
synthetic
synthetic
maybe something like that yeah okay
memory foam
i have one of those i don't love it but
i have every kind is what i'm saying and
and i use the pillow to suit my mood as
well you're pi i'll tell you why
some pillows are better for other things
i gotta sleep with six pillows i can get
away with four three if i'm dying
i got one between the legs all right i
don't like that pillow to heat up
yeah i go one on the neck yeah i don't
like that pillow to cave that's not good
for feather for me tonight right
i want to have it propped up and cool
you know so different things do
different things i also sleep holding
one
yeah because i hate with my arm to be
down here like this i like my arm to be
in a natural resting position right
you got to find an ergonomic thing that
works for you and then you're going to
see dividends throughout your day
because you're going to walk around with
a pep in your step
you're going to feel refreshed yeah i'll
never forget i'll never forget
we were in cincinnati you and i and when
when we go on the road together
we stay you know we get not we have a
nice room and we usually stay in one
room together again we're not gay man
it's just what we do okay it's just what
we do who what
all of a sudden if you want to save a
dollar sexuality comes into play you
can't make it yeah
that's what it is so so anyway and
you're sleeping you have your sleep
apnea mask on that's true so
you you know but see if any ass going
you have by the way you got to be real
comfortable
right to throw that mask on with
somebody so somebody you go so there you
go
you put the p you have the pillows all
around you all around all around you you
have a what
you have a pillow on your face you have
your phone with the alarm going off
on top of the pillow the alarm was going
off i [ __ ] you not for about 45 minutes
to the point
to the point where i was googling
because i know his parents you might
have came back from the gym
yeah yeah still going to the gym and the
alarm still going off where i was
googling
his parents names to try to get in touch
with a member of his family to tell him
unfortunately your son has passed away
and then thank god he woke up and we
figured it out but i
could i never in a mil i never i've
never met a deeper sleeper than you
no that's because of the mask though i
mean they they told me i saved your life
45 times a night or something like that
yeah save my life but also so betting so
do yourself a favor with the bedding and
you
and you and you kind of have also like
uh even what you just sleep where
right make it comfortable what do you
mean i just put him i go to sleep in my
underwear
i need to sleep on my underwear i sleep
in a t-shirt like a girl i i sleep in a
t-shirt but you sure don't panic sleep
shirts and you want to get
uh moisture wicking you want to get
stuff that is soft to the touch
you want to feel like you're putting on
a cloud so what do you sleep in i have
multiple things i have my favorite
t-shirts that i the right like
poly cotton blends maybe have a little
stretch in them what have you i'll show
you on the when we leave here i have
like one of my favorite ones right now
you'll touch and you'll be like i get
this
i get that one yeah and also i want to
tell you something and i don't want to
say
let's not say this product yet okay
until maybe because they maybe they'll
end up being a sponsor because you're
going to say
i go in hard in the paint with this with
this with this underwear brand okay
they also have now oh i know the brand
yeah i know their brand changed
the product that sounds talking about
which we're if listen we'll mention it
but you better cough up the money baby
we won't mention it yet
we won't mention it yet because we're
we're playing the game here but i'm
telling you right now
it's it's they're pretty expensive for
underwear i might have 30 pair
my goal is to never have to have enough
for a month i tell you what
the goals never have enough i agree with
you the way
i one time ate i'm talking about six
heads of broccoli just to try to get my
gas to a point so i'm gonna blow hole in
these underwear
i need to test them i need to factory
system i've had them for two years
yeah i have the same ass yeah it's the
same gas coming out yeah
all the time not as sweet withstood i
mean
nuclear bombs yeah it would be as if
those yeah how comfortable when you put
them on
do you forget you have on underwear you
know how many times do you know how many
times since i because you also put me on
hey babe you never know never know so
you beat that let's drop that out we
have another bit listen to me
all will be revealed this is like this
is like when geraldo went
hey when he went to al capone's uh
house there yeah and he dug through the
walls it was a big special at the end
they uncover nothing but some newspapers
matches and a couple empty bottles but
not us we're going to tell you what the
uh we're going to tell you what the um
uh what do you call it athleisure at
leisure
yeah i'll tell you what the best
athleisure is and the best underwear is
changed my life my life i mean when you
don't want to walk around all day
adjusting you don't want to walk around
sweating you don't want to pulling and
pushing and looking uncomfortable you
want to
you want to set it and you want to
forget it and if you're a guy like me
that has
i would say an above average length
of testicles they hang a little too low
this
underwear is perfect snug it's a cup
it's beautiful and athleisure i don't
even know athleisure existed
now not only have you told i mean i
thought
i was in that store that you would do
maybe just regular sweats right just
regular
someone found something between a
dungaree yeah and a sweat
yeah that also works in the gym but then
you could leave the gym and it's a
seamless transition
into shopping getting lunch this is what
athleisure is i
and i'm telling you i was in that store
yeah i was in that store buying athletes
that you told me to buy and i
and i met a woman who i thought this is
going to be my wife because these
these pants have changed my life this
woman's going to change my life and it
wounds up not working out because i
you know i neglected to tell the woman
that i already had a wife but
it's just but in my head the scenario
was this that's how much that that
underwear in those
pants changed my life so anytime you
give me a recommendation between the ham
locker and
can we say can we keep ham lacquer and
schlemmer yeah yeah keep in mind because
i don't think they're gonna come around
god bless
after we kind of said their product you
know shits to bed after three days three
years but no that's not bad
no it's not bad god bless them and you
know what you have a heavy head they
they
do and they discontinued the pillow but
they brought it back yeah so i might
just have to re-up
that's all because i had many good ears
with the pillow yeah i had many good
ideas with the pillow
i hope that one day talking about what a
thousand
sleeps i mean you sleep every day right
that's fine
also you should you should also change
your pillow anyway because bacteria
builds up in the pillows but what you
also want to do is you want to get a
really nice
thread count cover before you put your
pillow case on
that'll give you a longer life in your
pillow itself and then you
yeah and they're fair they're really
fair market value like 10 15
another thing about sal again because
we've been we've hung out so much you've
been on the road so much
i've never once i actually it happened
one time and i
couldn't believe it we were in a city we
always want we get into a city we get to
a new place
we go right downtown we find the shop
and we find the cute little districts
okay
not gay i've never i saw it happen once
i'll never forget i'll i remember the
exact moment in time where we were
in pittsburgh i remember the exact
moment he walked
past a candle shop and did not go
[Laughter]
oh i love a candy if he if there's a
candle shop in your town
sally v is going to go in there he may
come out i'm not kidding he may he may
spend a thousand dollars hard american
cash
on candles yeah don't tempt me with a
good time no absolutely not we have i've
there i've been living in cities where
we have to buy carry-on luggage to fit
his candles to get back i said
candles have become a problem with me
because they are as a fire hazard
they are dense and they weigh like five
pounds each and sometimes now with the
strict codes
all of a sudden i'm getting on i'm all
paid for but then my bag weighs too much
but then they want to bang out a hundred
dollars if you go over one pound
yeah so you know i'm buying a couple
candles all of a sudden the candles
now i'm incurring 100 penalties you
can't yeah no you're a home goods
you're a homey guy if if you wanna i
would say
i mean at this point you know you have
already career set up why not
branch off and go into interior design
why not do that why not say hey samba
khan is going to come over and design my
home do you want me to get a tv show
idea do you
oh my god hgtv let me uh i'm the
property brothers
call me max but god who knows how to
find oh yeah hbo
yeah hgo max is out now i'd love to
understand what it means but uh yeah
the jokers are on apparently we're on it
hbo go hbo now hbo verizon hbo max get
them all pick which one you like um
it is what it is no uh what we say oh so
the candle you know what i love i love
to set a mood
right i love ambiance i think that's big
too i love to get a setting to a place
where i'm free of of noise because you
know we work hard we work long and we
keep time with a lot of people with a
lot of projects
and there's a lot of noise and i got to
shut that noise out at the end of the
day sure taking
uh transcendental meditation yeah um and
i i
can't keep sticking with it two times a
day 20 minutes it's too much it is and i
plan to revisit
yeah me too but as of right now i
haven't done it what i do now to try to
take the place of that is i try to just
get up
i get up and then i sit up in my bed for
three minutes and i just try to
think good thoughts then i gotta brush
my teeth and have a drink of water
that's what i do i try not to just look
at my phone
for the first three minutes when i wake
up and i say i did that's what i was
doing every morning right so i would
wake up
and then i turn on my phone go on social
media and one hour
one hour laying there before i got out
reading social media and i read every
tragic story of the day and that's how i
started my day no good i stopped doing
it about five weeks ago
now i go on social media literally if
like someone tags me and i gotta read it
or have to post something for myself or
someone else like
i'll go on for that moment and i'm in
and i'm out and
guess what real life is so much nicer
than social media you really feel like
truly you've had that's had a
major impact on your mental health is
not looking at social media
i don't i i know a million percent
the effects were almost immediate wow i
felt the effects within days
right days what about the news you
watched the news no
see that's the other big thing too no
news no i'm tapping out now you don't
know what the hell's going on
i'll i will you know what i do now once
uh once every two weeks
i'll give it like a like like a half
hour read
you know i'll go to like as non-biased
the site as i can i'll give it a half
hour read just to get like and believe
it you know what's crazy
in two weeks the world changes like
every two weeks like i'm reading stuff
like holy [ __ ] i haven't looked at this
in two weeks and this is what it is now
yeah and then just just kind of dip back
out i'm kind of trying to more focus on
my personal health and like my family
you know or just my personal
relationships and smart
that change is right it just changed
right away yeah like i cuz you know my
health was taking
my health was taking a hit dude i was
like i was having insomnia never had in
my life
well you have the sleep happening
machine how that doesn't matter i was
here and let me tell you what okay babe
it's all right we're trying not to curse
yeah let me tell you let me tell you
what a night is like
when you got a mask on and you can't
sleep oh my god you want to you really
want to
find someone and just hurt them let me
ask you this now real quick because we
are in pandemic rules now
let's say let's say a guy comes in robs
your
purse comes in robs your house steals
all your masks you have to get to the
supermarket
do you can you go into the supermarket
with the sleep apnea mask on it counts
as a mask
absolutely not sleep mdms transmits air
it doesn't block it out it would be the
worst idea actually
it was one of the worst episodes if you
just took the two sides of the fact that
i just looked like i was like
literally making like a student film of
top gun it's like
what i'm saying if you have to enter a
store with a with some type of face
if the rules are face covering and you
have nothing else you could technically
go in your sleep apnea mask deploy
take first and foremost i'd probably
find a towel or an old t-shirt i'd cut
it up
and if you're really talking about what
i would do that's what i would do
really no i think maybe like four people
in my life have seen me with the sleep
mask on i'm one of them you're one of
them yeah
the other two of my parents yeah and
like maybe like you know i could have
taken a picture exploited you for
whatever i wanted anything you wanted
anything you wanted
all the candles you don't put that on
you know when you get into a new
relationship there's six months of me
i hate my life which is why i couldn't
get into relationship for a long time
because six months i was waking up
falling asleep in the middle of the day
sluggish hate in my life because i can't
put the thing on when you're laying when
you're laying to sleep next to someone
new i would love if that
i don't know if the show's going on but
the mass singer you come out with the
sleep apnea mask
that would have been well the old ones
were like this big now they've really
made it like
a little more convenient yeah the old
ones were like you were putting on
straight up headgear i'm supposed to
have a sleep apnea test
on wednesday i hope you pass but i i
hope so too but i have to get a covid
test
before you get to bed you have to take
justification where we live now you get
tested for everything i have to but i'm
going to lake george
i'm not going to have time i hope they
have did lake george you think that lake
george has a place that does covet tests
they said i cannot enter the building
unless i'm proven that i
i don't have you have one yet yeah i've
had three of them i'm waiting for the
antibodies
auntie or cove i've had three coveted
three antibodies all for three on both
okay i've had to test no antis never had
to cove
right is it i've heard no big deal i've
heard worst thing in the world
they poke you in the brain i heard it it
doesn't feel great
i gotta be honest with you it doesn't
hurt it hurt the nose won't hurt it gets
up to about after it comes out is it
like one of those things where you like
have an ice cream headache or something
like that no i didn't have any i didn't
have any residual headaches but it
jammed up there and it hurt like it
really ah i was like come on come on
come on like that and they're like sorry
buddy
you even said you even so so it it hurt
enough for you to tell them
you you said out of your mouth come on
come on come on yeah i don't like when
he took out
when he took out the the covid stick to
test me i thought he accidentally
took out two that would tape together i
said you have two in your hand he said
no this is the stick
i said excuse me that whole thing's
going up my nose
excuse me excuse me
i said excuse me and then he jammed it
up my nose
and uh and it's one of those and it
actually wanted the guy my friend my
daughter's godfather
oh yes he's an er doctor so he's the one
that did it and he did it in my nostril
and then he did it in my other nostril
and then i said and i said you know and
he said
we got to get both nostrils and then i
found out that you don't you only have
to do one he did it to mess around with
me
your [ __ ] yeah he did it twice and he
thought it was the funniest thing he was
telling all his co-workers yeah i just
did this kid cause you can have co in
this one and vid in this one but you
don't have it in both
he just said i caught this kid twice
but here's what i don't get how long
before you get the results
that one because it was done at his
hospital i got it in about six hours
but normally it's three to five days but
with the backlogger test it could be two
weeks
right so so chris yeah can you please
tell me
if you know of any place that i can go
if i want to get a little bit of
discreet counseling
off the top of my head the number one
place that i
i'm thinking of is betterhelp.com
well what's that i gotta go to some
office no what's that gotta pay
outrageous prices
no well i gotta wait two weeks to start
it nope you can do it from the comfort
of your own home
get a discreet licensed counselor
to hear whatever it is you want to talk
about
for a great price if you put in the
promo code hey babe
you actually get 10 off the first month
10 off american
go to 10 as far as i'm as far as i know
i was told 10 percent american money
wherever you could be in islamabad
pakistan
right you're still going to get off 10
american for the first month by going to
better help
not health better help help dot com
promo code hey babe b-a-b-e
ten percent off the first month it's
just it's the right thing to do
i can't believe i asked you that because
you had all the information i needed
sal a lot of times i'll see you doing
things
and i'll say why don't you just ask me
yeah and i'm happy that
on the podcast you decided to ask me
remember that time i was just putting a
straw into an orange and you were like
you should just pour yourself a glass of
juice
yes i should defer to you more often and
where do you think because
like i was just like you how many times
did you see me
putting the straw into the orange a lot
how did i learn
to start drinking orange juice
betterhelp.com
betterhelp.com is where i learned that
you don't have to do that it's just in
the commercial
do they stick the straw in the orange
juice you know what it makes sense
because we could all
use betterhelp dot com
backslash hey babe for 10 off can we
talk about one of your favorite products
sure blue chew wow love it
yeah and what does it do you chew it and
it helps you
helps get your penis to stand up then
that is what it is for
years sal for years before i went to
bluechew.com and put in the promo code
hey babe and got it for free
free i only paid the five dollar
shipping literally you just pay five
dollars
and you can have your penis back don't
understand the business model
it's crazy bluetooth.com promo code hey
babe they give it to you for free
literally for years before i found this
product as
as you know as many of you know i have a
very hard time getting an erection
sustaining an erection
i literally had a friend who worked in
the hospital i had
the things that shocked people back to
life when they have a heart attack i
used to put them on both my testicles
and try to get my guy to stand up and it
didn't work you defibbed your
testosterone i would defib
my penis and balls weekly before i was
gonna have sexual relations with a woman
or man depending on how much vodka i
drank
and it just would i would run into
problem after problem
the only time in the past few months
that i've been able to be
uh be hard for almost all of the day
is when i went to bluechew.com and i put
in the promo code hey vape
and i got it for free right to my house
it's made in the usa no it's not is it
it is it is it's prescribed online by
licensed physicians right so
you don't have to go to the doctor
anymore this one's used to be a taboo
thing yes we're normalizing this because
everyone deals with it right it's
cheaper than a pharmacy
they ship it right to your door it's
discreet there's no more awkwardness no
that's why you love it so so much as a
matter of fact since i've been on blue
chew now every time a postman opens
because i used to hate to have to get
the post i i said i hate to like
especially during the pandemic i got to
get the package from the person there's
germs
now the post people know to just leave
the package out the door because every
time religiously
i open the door i have a full erection
that's right i come out with a full
erection
from bluetooth.com promo code hey babe
five dollar shipping the rest is free
i mean just uh what i mean i don't even
know what else to say i have no idea
what to say other than
it i'm happy to be hard sell you know
what i want
quick and easy meal solutions that's all
i want we have that covered what do you
mean
hellofresh hellofresh does that hello
hello
fresh sends meals right to your door
if you're on the go if you want to learn
how to cook all these there's so many
things let me tell you cooking is
cathartic i just recently started 100
and i started it because of hellofresh i
didn't cook
i don't want to go to the grocery store
i don't want to worry about ingredients
no
and the bills are so much in the grocery
store cut down on your bills and your
food waste because you're buying too
much they send you pre-portioned
ingredients so you're not over buying
you're not hitting your wallet you're
not wasting stuff for the planet
uh they have easy eats offerings which
is like meals that are oven ready or
only take like 10 to 20 minutes that's
my next question i have a busy sketch i
only have 10 to 20 minutes to do this i
mean
i mean how many podcasts i'm doing we're
doing all this stuff i got 10 to 20
minutes babe if you have 10 to 20
minutes
you have enough to do hellofresh
hellofresh.com
hey babe10 you use the code hey babe10
and you're gonna get 10
free meals including the free shipping i
mean it's like how do these companies
make money
i don't understand it but if i tell you
right now you're you're
you're a goddamn fool if you don't take
advantage of this 10
free meals 10 free meals hellofresh.com
hey babe 10. 10 free meals including
free shipping and you want to know why
you get that deal
because it's america's number one meal
kit
what's up it's chrissy standups listen
february 12th 13th valentine's day
weekend
i'll be doing atlantic city new jersey
the celebrity theater then february 25th
to the 27th hot hot hot phoenix arizona
house of comedy then just added march 6
the vogel
red bank new jersey we just added two
shows there go get em the tickets sold
out real quick last time go to
chrisdcomedy.com for tickets
that's chris d comedy for tickets some
crazy stand-ups
let's have some fight yeah we're
expected to then
get it and then quarantine strict
for two weeks and then then they call
you and say you don't have it
right and then you're free to go out
again and maybe get it
yeah the day you go out again yeah
resets the results you got from the 14
days
that's allegedly what you said yeah so i
don't understand
how it's supposed to mobil how what is
it i don't
i don't i have no idea i have no idea my
mother my mother oh god
no i guess if you have it then you've
quarantined for 14 days
but then by the time he tells you you
have it right you
have been there 14 days and then you're
like am i over it or i can go back out
now but you don't know you probably have
to get another one and it's so confusing
and doctors and i don't think uh
some doctors are but a lot of doctors
are not doing a good job of explaining
test results to people my mother goes
and gets a cover test
gary's uh ex-girlfriend gary's ex yeah
gary's ex goes
goes and gets goes and gets uh a covet
test
she gets the results two days later they
tell her sign in on this portal
it says it says pending okay
then then she says okay so she she goes
and sighs on
she goes uh you know whatever the next
day signs it says negative
okay great so she's like i'm good then
she goes and signs on the next day she
got an alert you know new updated scores
it just says the number 19. so then
she's like
what is this now it just says pending
the number 19. nobody answers her phone
nobody
then then she signs on the next day or
two days later
they pull the test off the portal it's
just now her test results are in there
so for about to clean these do we clean
these
interesting do we need to clean them who
use them just us
oh that's right so this might have
droplets
this is all live folks this is unfolding
it's unfolding live
we should get new of these yes
but as of right now where is this the
wild west
so chances are if it has been used in
three days and it's been in a heated
environment hold on let's let's defer to
mike the engineer
yeah mike in three days in a soft
windproof uh
microphone cover do you know what the uh
the rules mike mike
our guy who's wearing a shirt that says
every [ __ ] and every place sucks
yes let's go to homeless pimp for the
update
yes yeah and giannis is
giannis is the definition of a
hypochondriac with this stuff i mean
i went to montauk last weekend and he
didn't want to do the podcast he's like
no not a few i was like i was around my
daughter and a couple other people in
the beach yeah and see what you're one
of only
you're one of not many people that i
have seen i'll tell you this
i mean you know it's not little it's not
like five people
but over the last four months it was two
people for like a month then it was like
five people
and ten and maybe but i'm talking about
the same people because i know that i
trust them that they're being strict so
well i know and it's because of that
like at least in the state of new york
governor cuomo just said this today
only in the whole state not the city in
the whole state only 120 people tested
positive for covert yesterday
because 9 million people only 120 tested
positive so odds are like 15 20 percent
that yeah so if you're very high odds
you're going to get it yeah okay
no but you're telling your mom 19 19.
nobody answers it
and then so for a week and a half she's
like i have no
idea right if i have covert or not right
they finally call it they say no
you don't have covert the tests are fine
she did well why did somebody write not
why was there in the number 19 on the
chart and they said that's your breaths
per minute you take about 19 breaths per
minute we tested that you're kidding me
yeah i swear she's like oh we tested
your breasts per minute while you were
sitting
in the chair so we put that on but they
just put the number 19 with no
explanation that's
crazy how funny is that it's like so she
thinks she has 19. she was calling she's
like i got 19.
[Laughter]
do you know why it's called that because
it's 2019. i didn't know that
yeah 19 that's why it's called that do
you realize i mean yeah it's crazy i
mean this whole thing
i don't know i mean i've been taking my
precautions i mean i got the mask on i
but what do you do like
like when i when you sneeze do you
sneeze into the mask did you pull the
mask down and sneeze
uh i haven't sneezed in the mask i don't
i told you i don't sneeze much
yeah i mean i i'm sure i sneeze regular
right but i don't recall
sneezing in the mask because i would
that would have resonated with me oh
[ __ ] what do i do with this right now
right i guess
there's nothing well because you don't
want to have your own sneeze in your own
mask i guess
i guess but yeah really that's the whole
point you cut to cover your sneeze
right so it'd be crazy to be like oh
[ __ ] i gotta sneeze
put it back on yeah dude one time i took
my daughter to the pediatrician she you
know she had a cold or whatever and they
said you know just this is pre corona
stuff they're like just uh
you know the doctor was like just you
know you know give her medicine whatever
and keep away from her you know like you
know
don't share cups whatever i'm like
absolutely getting her jacket on i pick
her up i literally pick her up
turn her around she's like waiting i get
it just seemed like turning around
my i'm talking to the doctor's mouth
open she sneezes full sneeze at you
directly into my mouth i felt it hit my
i felt it hit my tonsils
and the doctor said in about 12 hours
you're not going to feel well oh my god
i'd say 12 hours to the second
102 degree fever sick blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah
people don't believe this about me but
i've said it my whole life and i know
because it's happening in my entire life
so i have a thousand instances to refer
back to
but i go if someone likes when i don't
feel well if someone sneezes near me
right
and i'm close enough i go that's it in a
couple hours i'm gonna be sick
they laugh at me i get sick in a couple
hours i have
100 100 out of 100 instances where that
has been the case
yet people refuse to believe me right i
know when i'm getting sick i know how
why
i know how my body works yeah someone's
around me coughing all the time if i
feel it i go
i feel a tickle and they go it's
impossible for you to feel tickled in
your throat this soon
i go maybe i have like superpowers of
catching a cold
but i feel it and i'm always right and
it always happens without fail
i feel like that those three we have
three things in common and three big big
things in common we both we both
are you know on the fence are they
getting the straight you don't know it's
you make the call you we have we both
sound like the nanny
and then our immune systems are terrible
i don't know anybody
who gets as sick as much as i do except
you
we're constantly getting sick or now i'm
doing everything i can to prevent
getting sick so
i'll take i yeah tell him tell him what
you take because it's insane i want to
know it all no i do i take a lot of
herbs and supplements
no but what are they specifically
because one time you ran them off and i
was like what yeah okay so i take an
echinacea right i take an elderberry
tablet
i take a apple cider vinegar tap right i
take uh green tea but that's from
potassium it something else called like
saint john's warts
don't you take something like that saint
john's wood don't you take something
like
i take a baby aspirin okay by the way
talked to my doctor the other day he's
like why are you doing that
i said well i heard it was a healthy
thing to do it keeps like your blood
flowing and
an aspirin a day it's even on a thing
his little heart on the bottle he goes
yeah like in your 50s but you shouldn't
be doing that yeah i was like how long
you been doing i said
six to eight years or whatever yeah he's
like stop it stop it didn't you take so
much vitamin c that you crystallized
your own urine that's correct
i think i take a d 5 000 ius
i take a d i take a multi yeah i also
take a green juice
loaded with supplements and then i take
a c
um and i thought if you don't need it
you just piss it out
right so i would just want to be hyped
up at all times right max vitamins
yeah because when i get sick i go down
two to eight weeks common cold two to
eight weeks yeah i've been with you
times when you've been
floored eight weeks imagine having a
common cold eight weeks it's
happened to me it's happened to you and
i said never again yeah
i also said that would hang over and
that's why i really don't drink anymore
right but that's another story for
another podcast
we smoked the sativia yeah that's it yes
we did we smoked the sweet and low
yeah uh so no so i i said let me now i
go i get my blood work done
they said you want to do a little urine
too i said of course sure why the hell
not yeah let's do it also a guy doesn't
urinate a lot so this is you're
about once a day i urinate now i'm lucky
if i do i wear opposites i urinate no i
urinate
i urinate uh i have a whole hey babe i
keep cursing that's all right i'm trying
not to curse
yeah i we you're i you're right that's
the name of the podcast we're trying not
to curse
i urinate um every about every two to
two days
that's insane folks at home did you hear
what
mr volcano just said to the group yeah
he urinates about every two days two
days do you understand how
nuts that is to me oh i looked this up
and was supposed to urinate
six to eight times a day that's
normal i urinate every two days
for six to eight minutes
i swear to god i swear to god like
like you can play like two tracks off
like an oasis album and i will piss
through them and it's
and does it get to a point where when
you finally have to piss it's like you
have to go
it's like get out of the way nothing's
gonna stop us now like starting
a doctor ever commented on what that
could be from i don't really tell them i
get nervous i don't want anyone poking
around
my urethra i'm like just hoping for the
best on my own
see as much as we're the same we're
different because i'm the exact opposite
where i'm not lying you've sound i'm
being dead
especially if i'm drinking a lot of
water i probably urinate 15 to 20 times
a day
that's probably that might not be good
either it's not it's it's it's healthier
than me though
yeah i think i don't know i always
thought i thought it was like a big
great feature for myself
like i don't even i don't even i don't
get i'm not bothered with peeing
but then i i learned that that's really
really bad and then so
the other day i went to pee and i didn't
have to right they took my blood i was
getting the antibody testing and then i
said you want to do a urine test i said
let's do it
and then they said pee and i said what i
don't today i don't pee today
yeah today's not the day what's today
saturday no no i don't have any ideas
tomorrow night seven to nine yeah that's
what it is somewhere in there that's
what i have in my planner i don't p
and then i said try and i went in and i
produced p
but it was all the p i could produce was
just up to the fill line
right so now i tell you this because
there's a post script to the crystals
okay so i give him the p it was
everything i had
and it was just the right amount yeah he
sent it away it comes back he says this
crystal's in your urine i said what the
hell does that mean it says you can get
gall no not kidney stones right which
are apparently
brutally bad it's yeah giving birth yeah
given birth
yeah so i was shook to my core right and
i said what's causing this he said could
be a number of things too much protein
too much vitamin c not enough water etc
so a few of those things so right away i
i'm taking too much protein i'll tell
you that yeah because i i tell i
i eat protein products right not just
like chicken but like when i when i
leave the house if i want to have a
snack and i don't want to make sure i
don't go crazy i'll have like a protein
bar right
so i'm loading he goes you don't need
that much protein then he says how much
vitamin c you're taking we talked about
this
it was it was an insane amount i talked
about this the other day it was six
thousand percent of the daily life of
the daily allowance which is crazy but i
didn't intend for it
he said how long you've been taking six
thousand percent vitamin c i said again
probably six to eight years
and he goes you need to stop immediately
immediately
without taking the vitamin c yeah so i'm
like well it's gonna i'm gonna get it in
some things but i
lowered down about five thousand percent
on that right which is smart yeah
and now i'm trying to drink a lot more
water i'm trying to drink at least like
you know
eight cups a day what have you right i
don't always do it but but
since i've been with you i've seen you
drink about three seltzers now four
yeah so and i made him look this up is a
seltzer equal to a water that's what i
was going to ask i asked he said
a salsa will take the place of a water
if you just consistently are drinking
celsius
but if you get to the point where you're
very thirsty celsius
won't hydrate you the way that water
will so if you feel thirsty that means
you waited too long you're not drinking
enough water
have water but if you're just cracking
it open because you're making yourself
drink the water that you're supposed to
be
salsa could do the job there does that
make sense it doesn't but if a doctor
said it i'm here for it
so now i'm afraid about the kidney
stones dude just every time you pee
you're like here it's gonna if you get a
pain in your back you're like oh that i
do i think we're all like like that all
you got to do is plant the seed in my
head and it's manifesting since you've
said that
i feel pain in my goodness i could take
on i said
i might pass and you can get that at the
patreon
[Laughter]
no so yeah so maybe we'll do a patreon
one day no
um that's a um so yeah so i'm nervous
about that but then he told me
then we were talking to moore and i said
um he
he said the proper way to do i don't
know how he got now we got into
some real heavy piss talk professional
professional piss talk
and he was like the way you do it he
goes that could be the name of the
podcast you're a professional pistol
he goes you do is he goes did you pee
directly into the cup i was like as
opposed to yeah and he's like no you
he called it a technique swear to god
and he said no you you
not this but like you stream in place
yeah so he's like you begin to pee
pee for a few seconds and then swoop in
underneath that's the correct
catch midstream don't let your first
p go into the cup i said well i got news
for you doc it wasn't my data p
yeah i squeezed and anything i had was
start to finish in that cup
he said that's not then necessarily
going to be an accurate read the next
time i'm going to want to take you pee
again
and i need you to pee for a while and
then swoop in nobody's ever said that to
me
once in the history of me peeing into
cops how
what about your best what about
delilah's godfather he's going to get a
call right after we're done
you got to tell people these things how
the hell could i know i didn't
know i didn't know until he told me i
wouldn't feel slighted
jesus so so so in other words so now so
now they don't know a weird reading
it's not an accurate reading so you
could not you couldn't be in no danger
you could you could go back up to six
thousand percent
if you show him the midstream reading
possibly although
i want to err on the side of no kidney
stones so i just cut out i won't even
look at orange now right
the good a good uh a great uh friend of
the show joe bartnick um who's official
guy said that he passed a kidney stone
in the parking lot of a pittsburgh
steelers game once
i heard that yeah yeah he even and and
if you know joe barton he absolutely
absolutely did he said and he kept going
he told me he drank 10 beers yeah and
then he had to
pee like you can't imagine how he had to
pee yeah he said it was like you know
imagine drinking 10 beers
that p and no p would come out he was
pushing and nothing because the kidneys
was blocking so he said he just put his
hands on the port-a-potty wall
and pushed and pushed and pushed like
he's giving birth
and then he said it went ding and banged
off the side of the pony potty wall
and he let go uh in his words a quote
river of piss
into that porta potty holy [ __ ]
literally he said it was the most
painful thing
that he ever had to do but once it did
it he said he was done and then he said
he drank about another 10 beers and went
into the game
yeah but you could have more than one
stone it's that's just surgical
intervention is a kidney stone and he
pissed one out and went to a pittsburgh
steelers game that's wild
yeah joe barnick also the person who
didn't his shoes break it
hey janice's wedding didn't this shoe
didn't his rental shoes
didn't the souls come off of it and then
he walked around with no shoes and and
he put the soles in his back pocket or
something like that he had the shirt
didn't he yeah that was it he had the
solid shoes in his back pocket and then
somebody i forgot
no it wasn't barton because he was there
but somebody got so drunk they fell
asleep at the cocktail hour and woke up
the next morning they missed the whole
wedding
wow somebody did that i forget who that
was i remember seeing barney and his
tuxedo shoes were in his back pocket
yeah and then i looked down and like
i think that like the top half was on
but the souls ripped off yeah and he
didn't and joe barnick allegedly didn't
get a plus one but you showed up with
one of his friends he honest doesn't
know
again if you know bartnik if you know
barney it's just you know just some guy
that he met
at the airport brought him to the
wedding
i love joe barnick but um but so yeah so
that that's what it is with the kidney
stones i mean i
yeah i don't i don't know man medically
i am a big-time
what was one of your biggest medical
like do you like
have you ever had an operation that you
got like the only time i've ever gotten
anesthesia is when i got a colonoscopy
and what happened is yeah i got a
colonoscopy so i got it i'm threatening
to go out
i had to go out i'm nervous to go out
because they could do oh no not cold i'm
thinking of a prostate exam
oh you had the oscars i had a prostate
exam as well same time yeah well did i
ever talk about the time i
wouldn't want to be out if they're going
to do the prostate so what happened was
i feel like i don't know people are
going to be like look he's on tv this is
funny
i had it that's one of the pranks
i had to get i had a couple we had
murray get a prostate exam on air
really for a punishment and then when
when he was done we had to get a second
opinion
and everyone do a third and a fourth
opinion and we got i voted but
i i went i went it was a weird three
months so
first i i take a crap a big crap and
then
it and then i take it that's where the
story starts yeah
that's the big crap i take a big crap
one of those ones where like you know
whatever i'm friends with you know
whatever your friends i took a picture
of it sent it to me you think
is crap your go-to i never say crap i
like
i always say crazy crap i think i never
say crap
it sounds so funny i'm chrissy crabs
i don't know what i say
[Laughter]
like the crapper the crap yeah do you
want to say where's the crap where's
your crapper i
say i don't know i don't know i think i
said where's your toilet i think i just
i don't think toilet either i think
toilet's an embarrassing world toilet
too vulnerable like so much happens in a
toilet yeah and so much is associated
with a toilet i'd rather
you know i don't i don't say bathroom
you know what i say restrooms
sometimes we'll do what washroom wash
swear to christ you know what my father
said you say toilet you know what my
father would say if he was here in your
personal shooter
where's your men's room he would he
would say
[Laughter]
he wouldn't even say he would say do you
have a men's room
[Laughter]
no because people say like in in europe
they say toilet that's the
regular toilet toilet it's weird i say
toilet
so toilet's also a weird embarrassing
word so i took a picture of my crap yeah
and i sent it to my friend who's the er
doctor my daughter's godfather
just saying god bless this man look at
this turd like whatever and he goes
he goes he goes that's hilarious but let
me give you a call so he calls me goes
looking at that crap
i don't love the color of it really and
i said what do you mean he goes what gee
would you
i said i don't know like i don't
remember what i ate like probably pizza
and you know skittles whatever i ate
because i don't love the color of it i
would go to a gi doc so i go to the gi
doc i show him the picture of the crap
he goes we don't love that color we
don't love it when it looks like that
nobody likes the color
nobody people aren't in love with the
color what is the color
the co basically like you know i was
told like it could be
problems with like your bile ducts uh
liver problems gallbladder issues but i
mean literally what was the color
oh it was i would say it was more if you
pulled out a crayola crayon i pulled a
crayola crayon
one side of it was very dark almost like
black and the other side was like
lightish gray
so it looked like yeah it did it didn't
look great
so i go in odd colors odd colors
black and gray black and gray so then
i put i go and get the colonoscopy they
say nothing's good they
he says how about this at that point i'm
almost hoping something's wrong
because if i went colonoscopy for no
reason i would be upset well it's
interesting because and i was didn't
know how to feel about this but my
friend was a doctor was like that's just
what happens it's it's okay like it's
better
they say the colonoscopy was fine it was
fine they said we looked in you know
they're supposed to their proceed their
job is to look in my colon
he says the colonoscopy is fine so when
we're taking the cameras out we did
notice you have a small skin tag on your
anus so we remove that
i swear i didn't ask you i swear they
didn't ask me this they said you might
was it pro bono
yeah they said you might they charge you
they put a bandage on my ass
on my anus so so that is that wasn't
part of the procedure during it they
also did
actual actual plastic surgery on your
physical [ __ ]
he told me you already knocked out it
was just it was an easy snip
i said it could turn into something down
the line i know it wasn't part of the
procedure
but i just went with my gut and i
removed the skid tag on uranus
and i woke up and then he said you may
feel slight discomfort the next time you
poo
because you have a bit of a cut an open
wound on your anus
and and you know what it's just so they
said
did it hurt or was it was it no no it
was fine would you have known they did
it if he didn't tell you i would have
had no
i would have thought that the discomfort
i'm feeling if i felt the discomfort
while pooping due to the opposite
due to the fact that i had a six-foot
snake camera
in my colon see that's the thing that's
why i don't want to be out for any of
these things
right because i don't want them taking
liberties like right right you know when
i wake up and you tell me you just did
an
extra few things to my ass yeah and then
low and behold i said well why the hell
did my poop look those colors
and then you know they said i don't know
you know it could be this could be that
and then i
i'm trying to figure it out i realized
when i took the picture the poop i had a
snapchat filter on
so i said that's not no come on i swear
to god
so you had adjusted highs and lows i
didn't realize i had brightness
that you saw i took it i sent out a
distorted contrast was up to 95.
i had a snapchat filter on the poop and
then it made it look like it was simply
so your snapchat filter resulted in you
getting skin tag removed from your ass
and and a false colonoscopy wow yeah oh
my god
do you talk about that no that's a
that's i mean that's i mean that's
that's
that's a bit hand delivered right no i
mean it's just it's just what it is like
and then and then so that was that was
um that happened
never heard that story there you go i
don't know how i don't know this stuff
about you
like i don't know when i'm gonna i went
let me know when you think i know
everything
that happened mid-october okay fast
forward a few more of
two two months mid-december no early
december so six weeks later
me and my mother and my daughter go to
disney world okay so we're going to do i
remember i remember you went yeah we
didn't want great time whatever where
they charge you four thousand dollars
for a haircut
fourth yeah for the bippity boppity
boutique cafe yeah yeah
bippity boppity booty boppity the
bippity bop boutique i mean 650
to cut my daughter's hair like
cinderella it was a freaking full
rip-off
to have tea with the princess i swear to
god they gave me my pictures
we called disney uh to we were gonna we
were gonna surprise her with that
right and then we called you and they
said we're gonna do and you're like we
already did it yeah i did it
like just don't don't do it don't do it
it's like a thousand dollars
for them to cut her dead ends put her up
in a
which she took out about two and a half
hours later because her head was itchy
so so it was but whatever it's all they
know what they're doing disney they're
ripping that's why
that's why it's only 7.99 for the
streaming yeah because it's a thousand
dollars to cut the split entrance
of millions of children a day yeah you
hear that hbo max yeah um
so so 7.99 you get our full library
don't worry we'll get you for the cool g
when your daughter has a split end and
wants a
a french brain yeah that's what it is
that's where we get you
so um we i'm in disney
and i i keep having to pee which is
normal i told you i pee 15 to 20 times a
day no problem
but then it's getting to the point where
i have to go pee and
nothing's coming out little dribbles of
it are coming out
so i'm saying here we go here we go
meaning that
almost like i thought you had to pee but
you didn't so you had a p sensation
or you thought there was blockage i
thought well there was something there
was blocking there was no strength
behind the stream
first i thought it was blockage i said
let me let me text bartnik he's the guy
to know
then find out it's not that then it's
like
literally it's like oh i always felt
there was like pp at the end of my
peepee
so i always felt like there was pp at
the end of my penis where so it just
felt weird it felt like
wet down there and there was pee-pee
there so i called my friend who's a
doctor
and he says did is how you explain yeah
okay
and then he says to me he says look he
says chris he says
i'm not sure but you're going to be gone
for seven days you're not feeling
comfortable
he's like i'm pretty sure based on some
of the escapades you've told me about
you might have chlamydia again some
people the streets only have christmas i
thought double jeopardy you can get it
twice
you could get it twice i didn't know i
don't want you to get it you're in the
clear you're in the clear
no allegedly not so chrissy chlamydia
i now i'm in your i mean it's the chris
capades it's the crisco
yeah now i'm in a state of shock because
i'm like i'm with my mother
and my daughter in orlando florida you
know waiting to get on
uh it was called the slinky dog dash
that's what we're waiting to get on
that roller coaster waiting
coincidentally that's what you did to
get you the chlamydia slinky dog
exactly it's so so i'm
i go he says look i'm going to call in
i'm going to call i'm going to drop a a
pharmacist
a prescription into a local pharmacy a
local cbs or whatever
in orlando area i'm going to you know
throw i'm going to throw you a bomb
so thank you you just you just march in
there confident with like a mickey mouse
hat on
and just get get that's what that's what
i was gonna say i didn't
realize i didn't realize i walk in
i have the my first day at disney shirt
on
and my daughter had made me put on
because again i'm just in a height of
panic i had the goofy propeller hat on
walking to get std medicine from the
pharmacist
he goes and then he's
and the propeller and i just said
and he just said um yeah uh you know
azithromycin take this for seven days no
food uh no sex that'll be 1999.
and then i paid it and it was one of
those things where i was like wow
and then i posted a picture
my first day at disney and then i'm and
then i'm sneaking away each day because
again i'm in a little
time to apply to try to yeah put the
take the pills at him i was like what's
going on i'm like i got a headache
whatever she's like oh my god like
are you okay but you know i'm taking
this freaking std medicine and then
i posted a picture of me and my daughter
in front of the magic kingdom
i get put on this site called the dilfs
of disney
no way there's a site called the dilfs
ah that's amazing the dilfs of disney
and then that is amazing yeah the dose
of disney and then i come and then i
and then i'm yeah and then i'm sitting
down and an honor
i didn't know it's me my mother and my
daughter were eating at school i think
it was called um
uh oh it was called uh uh um gaston's
tavern gaston from
beauty and the beast he has a tavern in
in frontierland
well he did something after he did
something after the movie with him yeah
and thank you gaston no i don't know
what he's doing with his employees if
they got a small business
he comes out he's like i'm the manager i
heard there was an issue yeah
but gaston's tavern me my mom and my
daughter are sitting there and some girl
comes up and she goes oh hey what's up
she goes chris right she goes i just
show you in the dilfs of disney and then
my mom's like what's a dilf
and i'm just like i don't know i'm like
dads i love
fun mom disney and it was just like one
of those like back-to-back things so i'm
like i just got the chlamydia medicine
now i got to explain
to my mother what a dilf is and but you
know thank god
so so for three months between my
butthole and my pee hole there were some
issues but now i can comfortably say
poop feels great the p p is beyond great
that's p
there's nothing no no sex into the
golden age five months nothing you know
you know i'm not having sex during the
i'm not i'm not having sex during the
pandemic right no way yeah
so you know i'm not not even not yeah
i'm good who's
who i mean people are doing it oh my god
some of our friends i won't name their
names i mean they're going they're the
[ __ ]
guy i mean these guys are hooking up
with all these people
i'm like how do god knows i mean with
the pandemic i mean i'm in a
relationship
i still don't do it exactly yeah
yeah i mean for me it's like you know if
i show you my but it's like it's
interesting because if i showed you my
if i showed you my test results
and i said negative covert but positive
everything else it's fine
people don't want to get the covert but
they'll get the clap yeah people are
doing it
and you think it's because uh you think
that's that's that's
that's they just can't not do it they
just can't not do it i think sex is a
as important as breathing air and eating
food it's it's
it's actually on maslov's uh
physiological needs it's tier one
we could do a whole episode about mouse
it's a tier one what are the other ones
i forgot what the other ones are but you
know it's like is it is it because of a
release or is it because of human
intimacy
i think human intimacy and i think deep
down the subconscious
need to want to procreate i think that
that's pro
the same way strawberry medically
programmed to want to procreate
the same way strawberries have seeds on
the outside because when you eat a
strawberry a fruit that has a seed on
the outside
you eat it we eat it and then the
thought is we poop it if we were living
in the wild we poop it and the seeds are
in our poop
act as fertilizer the strawberries keep
growing you can't kill a strawberry if
you eat a strawberry
it just it you just replenish the more
strawberries you eat the more you make
the more you kill the more you make
like gremlins like gremlins wait i i've
never i've never heard of this in my
life wait
do other fruits do any other thing i
have seen on the outside there's a few
other nothing comes to mind
yeah strawberry strawberry is definitely
the headliner but i just blew my mind i
mean i know they're on the outside but i
never thought of it and i never thought
of why and that's a genetic thing that
the strawberry over years and years and
years why hasn't everybody else done
that
that can't come up to this i mean the
strawberry is who he is the strawberry
i mean look i'm not trying to i mean i
know that i know that we're living in a
cancer culture right now i'm not trying
i'm not trying to be
i'm not trying to be edgy or nothing but
the strawberry
it's overrated what the strawberry's
overrated so you take a blueberry over
strawberry any day
any day two times on sunday wow twice
no because a strawberry for me i can
bite into one i like it with cream i
like it with chocolate
alone it's a bit too sweet it's a bit
too much i mean like
it's a little bit too much do i like it
in a pound cake in the middle somewhere
nice nice do i like a strawberry ice
cream yes but strawberry shortcake
strawberry
yeah bite seed on the outside that you
know i can't just pound those i have one
i'm like i get it i'm over it i'm over
it
interesting i never thought in all these
years i've known you you would be so
disrespectful towards a strawberry
i'm just i listen i'm dropping some
truth bombs right now but no i
i yeah strawberry's not even my probably
not in my top 10 fruit
really yeah you know it's a fruit you
don't hear much about anymore
pears yeah i never heard much about them
to be honest
you know it's not like they dropped off
pears never meant anything to anybody
pairs of hay babe we're trying not to
curse you
pears are the step child nothing against
stepchildren i am one and i love my
stepmom i don't mean that i just mean
but
pears are the forgotten fruit right
pears are the staten island of fruits
right right with a forgotten bird nobody
else with a pear i never have in my life
no i don't crave a pear you're like a
pear maybe you like what do you call
those when you then they kind of uh
the ones that like you put in a salad
with a nice garganzola
a nice maybe a walnut and they put like
those uh can not candied but like
candied walnuts no the pear the way they
prepare the pear
they like um they it's like uh what do
you think [ __ ] like
a garnish it's not raw pear what do you
call it when the pear is in there but
it's like au pair
no no you know they're not chopping up
pear and just throwing it into the salad
no
pear is um pear i don't know it's like
um
it's like soft and more like a puree no
it's not pureed
everyone knows what i'm talking about
though do you know what he's talking
about
yeah just pear salad and see the way
they prepare that pair
but but you have you i mean i as a
matter of fact this is the
this is the reoccurring theme in my life
that i ask people that i get to know or
in social situations
i'm always asking about paris i ask
about it on set um i asked
i asked everyone put your hands up if
you bought a panel last year last nine
months
last six months last three months and
there's like three or four people out of
50 on our crew
that buy pairs every time they go to the
supermarket and no one has ever looked
at those people the same again
i wouldn't look at it because i don't
understand like who craves and goes
after pets and even when you bite a pear
you're like it's a fruit yeah it's a
fruit and it tastes like
a pear yeah it tastes like a pear but a
pear doesn't really taste like anything
else
yeah and it's and it's not great it's
almost like a lime lollipop yeah it's
not like i don't like green candy
and people do get offended because i
went into food dynasty just the other
day and i asked the guy
i said hey where do you keep the pears
and he was like during a pandemic i
don't want you to make those jokes
and i said what do you mean he was like
you know
it's a stop asking me about pears you
know we don't have them no
i don't even know when they're in season
i don't know i i don't know the
different types of pears does it come
off a tree does it grow out of the
ground
it comes off a tree are you sure about
that it's got to be a pear tree
it's a in parchment pantry that's right
and i'm saying a partner
in a pizza cartridge a partridge is a
bird
okay which i get into this with people i
don't know of birds of poultry fowl
chickens hens roosters i don't know the
difference between any of them but i
talked about this with the guys how
about this this is
we'll say this before we go the last
thing because i learned this because you
know during the pandemic
i had to teach my daughter you know
virtual classes you have to become the
teacher
pumpkin fruit or vegetable
i would i would think vegetable i think
it's fruit
i don't i would think it's a vegetable
pumpkin soup
um pumpkin is like last time it's
grilled it's put up it's put in a
grilled pear
they grill pears like that they roast
pears you ever find out what the answer
was
poached poached poached poached pear
grilled pear that's how they put them in
salads if you don't want it raw
right and that i like but you're getting
the chi the gardens all of the walnuts
you're getting the dressing
and the texture is fun it's a little
sweet punch it's in doses i'm not
biting into some raw pair right and then
also like
like yeah do you know do you know a
person that like is like oh pears on my
stuff like i guess
i never met a person that said they
don't like pears i
i have met my uh people that just eat
pears raw till the pit and throw away
like an apple
i something's wrong with you something's
wrong no i i would never do that if you
do that i'll tell you what i did once
get into a bait with a police officer
because i was eating an apple
and i threw the pit into the grass that
i was walking in and the officer said
i'm gonna give you a a ticket
for littering i said excuse me what do
you mean littering
i threw the threw it back from where it
came yeah it's biodegradable yeah it's
gonna grow back into the earth
had this whole debate he let me off no
ticket really yeah no ticket well
okay i gotta all right i also want to
touch on a time that you had to hand it
out with an officer because you thought
you were allowed to make
a right on right after midnight you
thought red light
yeah you thought red lights after
midnight were suggestions suggestions i
thought i
i'll never forget i'm driving casino
boulevard queens new york
i'm driving i could make a full stop at
a red light
it's 1 30 in the morning i make a full
stop and then i
i look all i look all four directions
and i continue to go yes all of a sudden
pulled over two officers come out of the
car one of them says license
registration
i said i can't imagine what i've done
officer but here you go
i say i can't imagine what i've done he
goes oh really
it's like you didn't know what you did
but that is bold from their end because
you blatantly blew a red light
and you're first thing it's almost
sounds like you're being smart you're
being the smartest
i can't imagine what i'd done but you
can't imagine what i've done
but here you go yeah you know so he says
you can't imagine what you've done huh
i said yeah what do i do he goes you
just went through a red light i said
excuse me
i made a full stop
at that red light i looked in all four
directions
i counted silently to three in my head
and i proceeded through the red light
with caution as i'm legally allowed to
do
[Laughter]
between the hours of midnight
where did you get it i don't know so
specifically that's what i thought
i genuinely thought that that's what my
driver's ed instructor mr mullins r.i.p
said
i said between between the hours of 12
a.m and 5 a.m in the in the
confines of new york city i can make a
full stop
and go through that light and then the
officer started laughing he was like
wait a second
so you think that red lights are
optional
past midnight yeah i said that's what
i've been told
and and he goes gives me two tickets
yeah one for going to the red light and
then one for um i think i had like an
out headlight or whatever
oh and then i said but i said to him i
said listen i said this will be
you know the headlight fine but this
will be fought in court because i know
my rights i know the rules
as soon as i get home because i didn't
it was one i didn't have a cell phone
that had the internet back then as soon
as i get home i google it
i said i can't wait to and then i mean
it's clear as days that you absolutely
cannot do that
no way in any way yeah right on red
maybe you get confused with
you right on red is really confusing i
thought red lights were 100 optional
just like by the way not a bad idea
yeah after midnight not if everyone's
following them as stop signs
yeah why not right sometimes you don't
want to sit alive for four minutes in
the pitch black alone
yeah but i two things that i thought
always i thought the red
the high school failed me in that the
red light thing and then i also thought
the way you could get hiv aids
was if i had sex with you
and we didn't use a condom and our blood
types were to a point that they could
mix and give aids i didn't understand
that
if the only way i can get hiv aids is if
one of if you have it
you give it to me so i would be power
just checking blood types left and right
i was paranoid about getting hiv or aids
for years if i didn't use a condom
because i said i'm not sure i'm not
going to ask this girl on the first date
what her blood
type is but i will go wrong but i don't
know if it's going to mix and get it so
those two things
i would say are the two dumbest things
that i thought i will say if you're if
your high school
um what do you call the driver's ed guy
yeah if he
somehow told you something weird like
that like my guy i remember
the one takeaway i have for mine he the
guy was like you want to be careful
uh most likely you don't want to drive
in snow right and we said oh cause you
could slide and stuff he's like
no he said if you get into the car with
a chunk of snow or ice on your boot or
shoe
and that's comes off your shoe and
slides down to the
if this is the pedal the this part on
the pedal you know you push
the pedal so this part if the ice
somehow
this is what he said if it the ice could
get lodged around that piece and freeze
on it
and then you won't be able to push the
pedal down for the brake because this
the pedal will be frozen wouldn't it
just
melt though from the heat of the engine
a million things i could have said today
a million things but the whole it was at
that moment
that no one ever took that person
seriously again as
children we were like no this guy does
not know what he's talking he doesn't
know how to drive yeah
it's almost like he escaped the mental
institution and was teaching driver's ed
i
actually ended up dating his niece for a
little bit and i brought it up to her
really i said i want you to somehow like
at a family party or something if you
can get your
uncle on the side and just ask him
[Music]
he's off the reservation what did she
say maybe a family member loved one
tells him
because he's got 32 kids in there when
we walk into the we walk into the
locker area when we leave the class
we're mocking him roundly
yeah it's like the wind starts to snow
like i can't drive it like why like what
about with the pedals freeze the pedals
are going to freeze that's going to
freeze
told us that what can you do nobody
drinks pear juice
no what an episode by the way we learned
so many things about each other
and then you know go tell us what you
think about paris what's your if you
have a story with a pair we'd love to
hear it yeah if you if you're a pear
person
you have all pair all the time let us
enter your world
really perfect i would love to i would
love to even talk to you even
yeah perfect oh no but then don't lie
don't lie i can
i'm gonna know if you have a prayer
person if you if you're lying yeah
hey babe hey babe
hey babe